hello reject nation I'm Greg Alba I am
John Humphrys we're gonna watch today
presented by alter a horror short film
of the smiling man this will do great
for YouTube monetization ya see at our
patron we do TV show reaction watch
along for many issues including attack
on Titan just started season 3 Full
Metal Alchemist Brotherhood I don't know
how many episodes John isn't on that my
hero academia we are also almost done
with season 2 and we also do the live
action show sometimes Gotham just
started season to Riverdale I don't know
where John isn't just sort of
supernatural yay and John does music
video coverage so we're gonna watch this
because when I have our top reward tiers
is whatever via your request you must
definitely do it put up on the youtubes
block worldwide or not let's do it
I did see there's like a lot of smiling
man source I think I did see one like a
to a year or two ago like two minutes
this is I'm one with the guy just
walking on the street and being stalked
but this is obviously a different one
it's creepypasta creation or something
right something on Africa just common to
meet in the comments call me an idiot
can't remember yeah oh that is Mickey
Mouse I thought it was the original og
one long before me Mortimer Oscar Oh
watch the video do penny was dude
yeah yeah hey peace candy hey Luke peace
can't so I shouldn't leave little girls
home alone well you should never be a
little kid you should never be in a
house
make a watch 90 minutes of this well
good because next year I so see it
scares with loud noises that's how you
know some scary sad random music jump
daddy
American balloons
that's is this is really about get a
white balloon
like the music smiling man's raccoon so
he's a scared thing with lights is that
noise they make yeah
I can see a [ __ ]
Oh
oh you grave
[Music]
kids if you're watching run at them
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
with the black balloon
[Music]
[Music]
dude
[Music]
ha
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Incredible Hulk and extra-special things
to be incredible a man this holiday
season yeah yeah come home for the
holidays and have a you know pale man
paint his face with your mom's blood you
reminded me of his name Richard Burke
break yeah yeah it's I was thinking that
what I was staring he's got that gone to
like fangled tooth thing going on yeah
it's all structure of his face and
everything yeah totally definitely
flashed him the smiling man when I saw
forever ago was it just a dude like
looking like a Jim Carrey kind of guy
stalking someone in a neighborhood yeah
this is a very different interpretation
I like the makeup on him too oh yeah I
mean it looks very much applied on a guy
but you know for a short film it's some
really good makeup talking like it yeah
like I've ever done something like that
it is just a guy with a bunch of makeup
caked on him but I think his mannerisms
and his like weird like contorted
looking yeah yeah it gives it yeah a
certain creature like quality that fur
the you know a short film like this it
drives at home in terms of the
mannerisms I liked how has laughed sort
of escalated yeah it's out but just like
a little bit of snickering and a little
bit more high pitch and then by the end
it's just like it's really loud that
thing where you're like can this guy
even talk or is he just gonna is only
capable of vocalizing and just like
making these grunts and gasps and things
like that you know because at first I
had this like very supernatural approach
and then I had it something that felt
very physical I mean it's very
supernatural in the beginning the hand
appearing tapping on the shoulder of the
balloons and balloons very supernatural
as we've learned but then by the end
because of the rule set up earlier in
the short film it's obviously
supernatural but it feels like this
could just be some guy yes yeah Farrell
do do broke in yeah felt very primal in
that capacity which I like when you
could do that with supernatural have
feel very physical the mom being dead
and poor girl for some reason just
standing I don't quite understand kids
and horror films a lot of the time yeah
I feel like there's a weird logic
applied to horror movie children they
just kind of are infinitely inquisitive
past a point of logical reason you know
they'll just kind of blankly walk up to
stuff and be like I'm gonna investigate
spooky thing in my big yes when I was a
kid if scary I wouldn't go anywhere yeah
or would at least be like very
apprehensive yeah apparently I would
stand and stare there for like 10 solid
minutes before making a decision to go
the other way would yeah there's a
certain thing about like oddly stoic or
movie children in terms of what the
piece was trying to communicate I'd
appreciate it the music was really good
I think it's the cinematography was
excellent when she's walking closer to
him when he's around the corner of the
kitchen counter and it said above shot
angle and it's following I thought that
was a really cool stylistic touch the
build-up to seeing him in full form and
seeing his face was very eerie very
creepy you know this is like a fun short
film I feel like they were trying to
like go to pitch this to make it a
studio project or something because I
get very logical those sort of things
like the mom there the whole time she's
not see her mom dead there in the corn
the whole time yeah I start to question
that before the short film mood piece
and all that I thought they did a very
effective job yeah well I think mood
piece is kind of a good subcategory to
place this in because of all the horror
shorts out there I feel like a lot of
them go for that structure of like
here's a intriguing setup to kind of
pull you in get you leaning forward and
then up at the very end we're gonna do a
reversal gotcha kind of thing yeah and I
feel like this didn't really do that you
know you kind of just have this little
unfolding story that becomes this weird
what is happening moment you know and in
that way I kind of appreciated that it
defied the structure that I'm used to in
a sense and I think it definitely got me
you know in some moments it differently
having me pulled in I could have maybe
Saturday used maybe like one more punch
but other than that I mean I thought
yeah they had a good grip on the mood
and the music and on stuff well thanks
Erik for recommending this mr. Horst man
and I know why this guy likes or guys
pretty much Norman Bates you know he's a
good
it he takes care of his mom yeah go is
refers to her his mother mother and I
just feel like one day Eric's gonna snap
and murder his Jewish mother which will
be really funny yeah oh yeah because I
mean think of him in like all of her
different outfits and stuff like that
and you know trying to like run a
bed-and-breakfast out of his house while
also being his own mom or how to
transform I think matricide is one of
the funniest crimes that anyone could
ever commit because people are always
like the cliche is tongue man that mom
wants in a killer a kid but when you do
the role reversals are always funny
always that's why the Ghostbusters
reboot words about oceans 8 was
successful because when you roll reverse
it you kill it the cake kills the parent
you just you don't see a common that's
the true key I can't wait for that
patreon message when you and you murder
your mom yeah send send send pictures no
man part of the funny is you don't see
it oh yeah of course that's right it's
always veteran or imaginations right
yeah yeah you can't it's gonna look fake
and like you know not scary if you just
show it is half the comedies aren't
funny because I can see in here is not
knowing what anyone's saying cuz that's
the funniest of all it's just what you
imagine guys you can subscribe to the
reject nation click that notification
bell and check us out on patreon bye bye